i thought he'd be taller stan lee is far
from the only actor to appear as
multiple different mcu characters are
you tony's stank although he's
technically considered one character the
watcher informant but we won't dive into
that here it's kind of like the jarvis
versus vision argument let's check out
which actors have taken on more than one
marvel character it's clover time it's
catchy right number one she's looking a
little less blue these days since she
got a bigger role
gemma chan first appeared in the mcu as
minerva in captain marvel they liked her
performance so much and regretted using
her so sparingly that they just had to
bring her back as cersei for the
eternals in fact it was kevin feige who
approached her himself and said they
were going to find her a character
alright obviously blue skin makes her a
different person just roll with it guys
don't ask questions we want to see
literally all of our long-lost actor
friends come back alien swapped once
number two the triple-headed threat
taika ytt not only directed thor
ragnarok he also played the beloved
character korg my name is cork i'm kind
of like the leader in here and one of
the three heads of hajju
the left one chris hemsworth played the
right head
ytt also did the mocap for the fire
demon serta and even some for the hulk
when mark ruffalo wasn't around ytt is
one of those actors where we would be
happy if he played every character in a
movie but who would direct if not him he
is known for acting in movies he's
directing but that might be a bit much
for the guy well it didn't all right mom
and dad i didn't
number three before captain america
evans was super hot captain america
wasn't chris evans first time putting on
a super suit he played the human torch
in fantastic four six years earlier than
his mcu debut and johnny storm was
actually his breakthrough role love the
fantastic four series or hate it one
thing is for sure we wouldn't have had
captain america like we grew to know him
if we didn't first have johnny storm
number four this guy carried the torch
keeping on track with fantastic four
actors we also wouldn't have that
fantastic performance by michael b
jordan as killmonger if we didn't first
have the reboot of fantastic four when
he carried the torch quite literally
playing the same role as our beloved
chris evans he went from hero to villain
though and we've gotta say his
performance is strong in both but we've
got a preference for the baddie number
five marvel's most versatile actor our
boy ryan reynolds can play literally
anything like deadpool deadpool again
and
himself but in all seriousness we would
watch him in anything he did also play
hannibal and king blade trinity so he
does have some variety but let's face it
we go to ryan reynolds movies for ryan
reynolds and would be sorely
disappointed if we found he was acting
like anybody but himself number six a
whole batch of cumberbatch in one place
benedict cumberbatch acted across from
himself in doctor strange
a lot like eddie brock and the symbiote
in venom if you recall a little moment
where dr steven strange found himself
banishing dormammu in a time loop that
was cumberbatch playing off of
cumberbatch he did all the facial
capture for the character
number seven you think heimdall could
sense the deja vu idris elba played both
heimdall in thor and moreau in ghost
rider
the interesting thing that ties both
characters together are their bright
golden eyes elba has said that the
process is different between the two
films thor relied heavily on green
screen while he said ghost rider was
much more hands-on number 8. jackie chan
thought women belonged in the kitchen
until she kicked his butt ok she said it
jokingly don't go boycotting jackie chan
now you can spot michelle yo in both
guardians of the galaxy 2 as aletta
ogord and shanxi as aunt jiangnan
i'm glad they you know they look at me
and they think of me in different
characters she loved returning to the
marvel family
number nine can't nothing bring him down
john favreau has been with us since the
beginning of the mcu playing happy since
iron man in 2008 but he's been around in
another marvel role dating all the way
back to 2003 where he played foggy
nelson in daredevil what's next for
favreau happy foggy maybe they should
have had him play nick fury's brother or
something next can you picture it we
sure can't
number 10. a tale of two merida's
kenneth choi played jim morita a world
war ii soldier in captain america the
first avenger and then two generations
later the actor reprised the role in
essence when he played principal morita
in spider-man jim maria's grandson
marvel isn't shying away from the easter
egg either number 11. the hero with the
most name changes
anthony mackie has been playing the role
of sam wilson since captain america
winter soldier and while he was just a
dude disguised as another dude in falcon
and the winter soldier if smiling tiger
was ever brought into the mcu for real
do you think he'd be played by mackie
even has a bad nickname
number 12 maybe she's just always been
one character you never know with these
shifty types rebecca romain played the
mutant shapeshifter in x-men for the
original trilogy and had a small cameo
in first class before passing off the
role to jennifer lawrence but that isn't
the only role she played in the marvel
universe she also played joan in the
2004 film the punisher right in the
heart of her time filming for the
original x-men trilogy
number thirteen does it count as seven
characters if five are identical patton
oswalt's most recent stint in the mcu
was as the voice of pip the troll in the
eternals before that he played five
identical brothers in agents of shield
and before that he played hedges in
blade trinity
from the look of things these roles
aren't super conspicuous so there's a
good chance we could see the guy appear
again in the future
number 14 he literally played all of our
favorite characters
james gunn loves to cast his brother
sean gunn in whatever he can that's how
sean got the role of franklin in the
guardians of the galaxy he also did a
bunch of mocap work for the mcu too
playing characters rocket and groot
number 15 sometimes the biggest heroes
are ordinary people joe russo is kind of
an interesting guy not only did he
direct avengers end game he also played
dr fine in captain america winter
soldier theo brass this time in captain
america civil war
and our favorite happened in end game
where he played an openly gay man
struggling with the loss of his partner
after the snap he's great
number 16 we need more of him please
nathan fillion is friends with director
james gunn and so has received a couple
cameos in the franchise you might be as
surprised as we were to find out he
played this prisoner in the guardians of
the galaxy franchise fillion was
supposed to have a bigger role in
guardians of the galaxy too as simon
williams aka wonder man but his scene
was cut short and he was put on a
different project modok voicing the
character instead we're sad about what
could have been but hopeful for what's
yet to come oh nathan nothing is set in
stone with marvel and from the easter
eggs floating around the web we still
think fillion might have his day number
17 we're seeing double double imogen and
isabella poynton have split the part of
two different marvel daughters they
first appeared in guardians of the
galaxy as day's pink daughter roman and
then they came back to play lila barton
one of clint barton's daughters for age
of ultron although the role went to ava
russo for the hawkeye tv show
number 18 is he a boar or is he ghooly
you can't be both tony curran has played
a bunch of roles in marvel movies he
played thor's grandfather boar but
before that he played finn cooley a
gangster in daredevil and outside of the
mcu he played a vampire priest in blade
2 and a division x agent in x-men first
class other than stan lee he's probably
the actor who's appeared the most in
various marvel projects
number 19 we bet marvel regretted giving
him such a short part aaron taylor
johnson played quicksilver in age of
ultron and while that is his only
recognizable credit the man is coming
back for craven the hunter in 2023 where
he will be playing sergey kravenoff
number 20 of course the only helpful
karen in the world is a.i
jennifer connolly voiced karen
spider-man's ai user interface what's so
fun about this casting choice is jen is
married to none other than iron man's ai
interface
the scepter is alien jarvis vision actor
paul bettany but this isn't her only
stint in a marvel film of course you've
got to go all the way back to 2003 to
find her in hulk
number 21 the guy's good at playing
villains what can we say josh brolin
played thanos in end game and cable in
deadpool 2. the thing that's interesting
is he wasn't cast as thanos from the
beginning the role was originally given
to damien poitier for this teaser moment
in the avengers mid-credits scene but
casting for a tiny teaser and casting
for the mcu's biggest villain are two
different things and so josh brolin took
on the role
number 22 marvel really did him dirty
recasting him like that while we're on
the portia train he also played two
different characters in the mcu along
with the uncredited thanos he played
crossbones mercenary in captain america
civil war try to save as many people as
we can so this is a note to all of you
out there who hope to end up acting in a
marvel movie one day don't say no to a
one-liner roll if they like you enough
they will find a way to bring you back
even if it means spending time and space
to do it what cross casting surprised
you the most did we leave out any of
your favorites let us know in the
comments thanks for watching